good afternoon everybody it's so
nice to have you with us uh we have one
more student joining us
um welcome to well welcome to rocky to
you science outreach
uh and our lab backstage program my name
is jeannie
um i am coming at you from not
rockefeller university but my kitchen
table
um so uh welcome and
i am the director of rocky new science
outreach which basically means i like
find money in places to pay people
um so i'm so happy to bring you here
with us today
and we're super pumped to
introduce you to one of our awesome
scientists thank you everybody i will i
say this is one of the most impressive
classes i your your pictures are great
because usually
we have uh students who are not putting
their cameras on which is no judgment if
you don't want to use your camera
but uh thank you it's nice to see your
faces
um so i'm gonna hand it over
to our friend kip um who is
a scientist and kip is gonna talk about
their work
so kit take it away
hi everybody um like she said my name is
kit
i grew up in atlanta georgia and i've
always been interested in science
i would try to go to like whatever
science outreach events were available
to me as a kid and
then when i got to university i studied
ecology and i got really interested in
insects and
specifically ants so i've been working
on those for a few years and i a couple
years ago i moved
to new york to rockefeller university to
study antscere
so that's what i'll be talking to you
about today and
i'm just hoping that we can have sort of
an engaging conversation about this
so um i'll probably ask some questions
and if if i ask a question you can just
feel free to unmute yourself and answer
or if you have a question for me at any
time there might be
an option for you to raise your hand in
the zoom like a button you can click
and if you do that then i can be
interrupted and you can ask it
um i heard from your teacher
that you guys have been recently talking
about invasive species
and i'm just curious uh to hear from you
guys what what sorts of invasive species
have you been talking about recently
i see juanez raising his hand
um well we've been doing a project
uh where he some students are now
requests for all of them
uh we choose an invasive species like i
chose
cane toads um and yeah we're doing a
project on it
very cool is anyone else would anyone
else like to share
what invasive species they chose for
that project
looks like james raised their hand
[Music]
yeah okay so the invasive species that i
have
is um seamoth oh very cool
yeah so um i i was excited to hear you
guys have been talking about that
um one thing that i sometimes like to
think about is
when an invasive species moves from
where it used to live into a new
territory
um you know what's it eating is it
eating different food that it used then
it used to eat
um whether or not food is available is
probably pretty important for whether
the species can actually survive in the
new habitat
and i wanted to well i don't know that i
see the polling option available i
thought i might
give you guys a poll in in zoom but
that's okay
i just wanted to uh ask
what do you guys think so i mentioned
that i study ants i'm curious what do
you guys think ants eat
uh i see grayson grayson would you like
to answer
i think ants eat plants and other things
they find on the ground
that's a really good answer does anyone
maybe there's somebody else who has
another answer
uh uh i am i mispronounced this name but
junika
it's janita janika sorry about that
but i think they eat kind of like what
humans eat because they
sometimes take the human's food like
stuff like bread
and potatoes the
like normally what just humans would eat
and also
plants awesome
both really good answers um and and both
frankly correct uh ants eat all kinds of
things
um and it really just depends on what
species you're talking about and where
you find them so like you guys said
especially if you find them in an area
where there's lots of humans around they
will probably eat things that humans
drop on the ground
um i get asked a lot the following
question which i always find a little
bit funny
and that's what's the difference between
the red ants that i see and the black
ants that i see
and so it seems like to me a lot of
people when they think about ants they
have two categories in their mind
red ants and black ants in fact
we ant biologists know the ants are
incredibly diverse
there are more than 10 000 different
species that we've identified and
there's probably many more
um and they they eat a variety of
different things some of them are
strict vegetarians
some of them are strict carnivores and
hunt their food
some of them actually will will
basically farm other
insects and exclusively eat
eat what they provide the thing that all
ants basically have in common is that
they live in colonies
so they live in close proximity with one
another
usually family groups
and they uh they interact with each
other extensively there's lots of
communication going on
i'm curious um how do you guys think
ants communicate with each other
so as humans we talk with one another
um uh grayson i see your hand face
they use their antennas like how bees
use their antennas
nice yeah that is true the antennae are
involved there was
uh uh javane i
probably mispronounced that but i saw
your hand raised
yes it's giovanni giovanni i'm so sorry
it's okay i agree with grayson they
like connect or talk with their antennas
cool uh so their antennae are intimately
involved
um i'm just going to tell you that a lot
of what they're doing is something that
some members of the lab here recently
learned is that a lot of what they're
doing is smelling
there's a little bit of tasting involved
but a lot of it involves smelling
chemical components called pheromones
that the ants release themselves
and i wanted to show you an example of
ant social behavior in the colonies
and ant communication via chemicals
that a a member of our lab who's
recently
graduated um
has studied are you guys able to see
this picture
that i'm supposed to be sharing cool i
see some thumbs up
um so this is a right now it's a still
image but i'm going to show you a video
and can you see my mouse as well
actually by any chance
so right here this is an ant and these
are a bunch of other ants
and all these ants are basically sisters
and they live in a colony together this
is sort of their
their nest area this is a
arena that they're allowed to walk
around in and this is a tunnel between
the two
and this is a setup that i'll show you
in a minute that
vikram chandra a former student in the
lab
constructed and what he wanted to study
was how these ants
get their food basically so the ants we
study in the lab
they exclusively eat uh the brood of
other ants
so that's what this is right here it's a
a an immature
ant that we've dyed blue with food
coloring so that you can see it in this
video
and we're gonna watch how these ants
find and how they collect
their food
so you can see she can she's kind of
exploring the arena
she hasn't found it yet
there we go
what do you guys think she's doing with
the uh the food
you can just unmute yourself i think
um i think she's trying to take it to
her sisters
yeah maybe i just think she's trying to
eat it
yeah maybe oh what's she doing now
oh wait um she's gonna as well her
sisters there's food
and so so they can help carrie
it looks like that's what she did huh i
think she signaled them to come over
oh man how do you think that she did
that
um
oh yeah it looks like it so you can sort
of see they've all sort of aggregated on
the piece of food
and then you've got some that are sort
of running back to the nest
to checking things out um
yeah all great answers um so
one um the thing that i wanted to
highlight was how
did you guys notice anything different
about
when the first ant was going to the food
and when the other ants went to the food
uh juanes i saw your hand
um so i think the difference is that oh
i have two
answers so one of the differences is
that
that um they weren't with one and they
weren't um
well that ant wasn't really uh eating it
i thought i was gonna eat it but then uh
all the
ant all the other ants in that one and
they all came together
and they started i think they were
eating it
cool so what i just want to replay
is first we're going to sort of watch
in this fast motion the path that the
first ant took
when it left the nest it sort of takes
this roundabout route it doesn't really
know where the food is
it finds the food
and then it goes kind of in a squiggly
line but
more or less it doesn't go directly back
to the nest
but it finds it finds its way back and
my question to you
is does that look similar to the route
that its
sisters took when they went and found
the food
they don't run straight to the food
either they sort of follow the path that
she
took back does anyone have an idea
of why and how they took the same path
that she took
um i think it's their sense of smell
okay so what are what do you think
they're smelling
that um the the sister who killed it
would went in that path so they will go
in that path
to eat it that's that's absolutely right
so um they
what when when she's coming back we we
can't see it because
um uh because we're not looking at the
right angle
but she's actually dabbing her abdomen
against the ground as she walks and
she's laying down
little bits of pheromone that then are
the ants can smell on the ground as they
as they
are leaving the nest um
the other question i had is let's just
watch her walk
into the nest again
how do you think she told her nest mates
that
there was food to be had like what do
you what how do you think she alerted
them
junika
i think she alerted them by using the
little
um um ant thingies
her antennae yeah
uh that's very close and so actually
they they actually smelled what she
how she alerted them using her their
antennae
um but we're not sure where it comes
from but somehow she
released some kind of pheromone into the
air that they were able to smell
um i'll share this video with you guys
so that you can
look at it more if you'd like but
for now i'd like to sort of show you
more around the lab
and i'll just briefly show you the type
of
arena that we used to film that video so
this
is the unit that that was filmed in or
it's one of them
and so this is where the nest area was
this is where
the foraging arena was it's sort of
falling apart in my hands
but these are little areas over here
that
we we keep open so that we can water the
plaster that's underneath so basically
they're walking around on
uh plaster which is something you might
find in like a wall somewhere
and we keep that wet so it's sort of
similar to soil that the ants are used
to walking on
to allow them to you know feel
comfortable and be able to survive in
their environment um and i'll just show
you briefly how this can be
taken apart uh basically vikram
he he used like a laser cutter to cut
this plastic in this way that this was
used
and basically it it comes apart just
with these screws
you can sort of if i can unscrew
it you can sort of see
how it was assembled
and basically there's this top layer
that we can remove
uh this second layer that has this mold
here
then there's a layer that's just plaster
and it's sort of beaten up there but
that's what they're walking on and then
another layer
underneath and i'd also like to show you
sort of
where uh where we filmed
that video and for that i'm going to
take you guys around the lab
uh this this is the lab where we do a
lot of this work um
uh let's see
got some ant pictures on the walls that
we're passing there's another one
the close-up picture of an ant
um so the the room that i'm about to
walk into
it's probably in reverse for you i'm not
sure but it says usda
containment facility the ants that we
study they're actually invasive species
um not they're not invasive here yet
uh but they potentially could become
invasive here so we have to keep them
under strict
uh containment quarantine control so
they don't get out
uh and we're going to walk into
a climate room so it this this room is
maybe able to hear some of it it's
temperature and humidity controlled so
that
the ants like how it feels
and i'm just going to show you
um this is
these are cameras right here that are
pointing down
at uh at this nest that i laid down
there that's the
the um the little mess that i just took
apart for you
and these are a bunch of cameras just to
sort of show you
uh how how this is set up we have to get
the lighting right so there's these
strips of led
lights along the wall um
and that's sort of how that video was
taken
um while i'm
in this room i'll also show you uh
these are just little tupperware boxes
that we
keep colonies of amps inside and i'll go
ahead and try to
open one up for you
it's it's like very similar tupperware
to what you might keep
leftover food in um
so we put plaster in the bottom and then
we put ants inside of it
so i don't know how much you can
see all those little brown dots are ants
and the white thing or the lighter
colored things that they're walking on
top of
those are their their larvae their
babies
and then over here is their food so ants
on top of babies
crawling around food and then
plaster floor
pretty fun yep what kind of food is
is in there so we
uh the food that we feed them is
basically
uh it's all the larvae and and puberty
of other ants
so other they eat other ants basically
um questions oh absolutely yeah yeah
please
so i think we have i'm gonna james it
would be great if you can ask your
question
okay my question is like
no
okay so my question is like
did you just like find them and pick
them up or did you have to like buy them
and then just like
you have to buy them oh okay yeah
so the the ants that we study in the lab
we basically uh found in in the field
somewhere so
uh the the professor who runs this lab
collected these ants well this colony
[Music]
it came from uh san quoi in the
caribbean
an island in the caribbean and he
brought it here to the states
uh just to study and he had to get
special permits to do so because like i
said this was in
a potentially invasive species
uh and then their the food as i
mentioned it's also ants some of that we
go
down to georgia and collect and then
some of it we
you can buy because in certain places
uh ant larvae are considered a
you know a food that people can eat and
so you can buy them in large quantities
for that reason
wow can we take another question
absolutely and i'll be doing it i'm
going to sort of
walk to another area uh but go ahead and
ask please
hi jeff uh javane um uh please uh
feel free to ask a question and i am
sorry if i pronounced your name miss
incorrect
oh yeah it's divine and
um my question is when you take the ants
from wherever they were from uh do you
give them back when they when they're
enough
uh the the unfortunate answer is no
we do not we do not take them back
usually um
the the ones that we study in the lab
here we
we basically maintained them in the lab
since um
since we've had them um
there are some cases when when in the
past i've taken ants
and when i'm done doing what i want to
do put them back but i think more
typically
we don't okay
and can we also take one another
question before moving on to the next
segment from
alderas absolutely
when the ancillary eggs how big are the
eggs and how many do they lay at a time
that's a that's a really good question
sorry you asked how big are they and how
many did they lay
yes so
[Music]
um i i think i'll show you something
pertaining to this you'll be able to see
the eggs in a second because we're going
to look at some ants under the
microscope
but usually in our case each ant
probably lays
one or two eggs
per or maybe three i'm not sure per egg
laying
time so basically they about once a
month they'll lay eggs
and so probably each ant lose one or two
eggs per month
in our case but in some species of ants
that have ant queens which you may have
heard of sort of like
queens of bee colonies ants also have
those
uh the the answer to this question can
be like dramatically larger so
in the case of army ants the queen is
enormous she can be like this big
and she is actually pumping out several
eggs per second
so like as many as like seven eggs per
second she can be laying
um she's basically an egg assembly line
wow
maybe i can show you a picture of those
in a second
all right one last question from juanis
and then
we'll get we'll give you the floor there
they're just a lot of questions coming
in
that's great all right so uh
have you ever seen like uh one of the
how do ants act when they're like sad
oh uh
it's hard to know whether the ants are
sad
because well i don't speak their
chemical language
you know but uh what i will say
is that some ants
you know maybe they're just loyaling
around the nest not doing very much
and so ants can vary in how
and how active they are basically that
doesn't necessarily mean they're sad of
course they could be very happy not
doing anything
but uh yeah so i'm not really sure the
answer to that question that's a good
one though
um i'm briefly just going to go and grab
some ant nests and we're going to look
at them under the microscope and i'm
happy to take more questions throughout
um but i thought it might be fun
to look at some ants live
that sounds amazing ants are so
beautiful under the microscope has
anybody ever seen him
ant under the microscope before
yeah okay so this might be one of the
first times and so i'm gonna
uh call on another person for a question
uh
thank you and i have a question um have
you ever came in close
close encounter with the queen bee i
mean nothing be a queen ant
all the time uh i i used to
specifically study the queens and uh and
what they did
basically in in fire ants which are a
big invasive species of ants in the
american southeast so in georgia where
i'm from those are
hard to hard to walk two feet without
running into a colony or stepping into a
colony and getting stung
but i i was studying the queens of that
species and
they do indeed look very different from
the workers maybe i can show you a uh
picture in a little bit i'm gonna all
right
addison go ahead and ask your question
how can you tell the difference between
the queen bee i mean the queen ant
and the other ants that's a great
question i'm gonna run
and just grab a picture that will very
quickly
demonstrate that answer awesome awesome
they have a lot of really cool images
and pictures in their lab
and we're going to have a whole bunch
of videos and pictures from their lab on
our website that
we'll make sure that your teacher gets a
link for so that you can check it out
it's really really cool um let's see
i guess juan is if you want to ask your
question
uh i think kip has earpods on so kid
will be able to hear you
i'm still listening
so my question is uh can you
tell us some some and three at least
three
interesting facts about ants we might
not know
so this is a picture of an ant queen
that's the queen and that's the worker
so it's pretty easy to tell just by
looking at them
and this is a very extreme case so you
can actually see the white stuff like
that that's her body it's just
so full space like her egg laying
machinery gets so big
and you can even see right here that's a
pile of eggs coming out of the tip of
her abdomen
um her egg-laying machinery basically
becomes
so highly developed that her body is
like
severely extending to accommodate it
um in most ant species it's a little bit
less extreme
looking but you can still tell the
difference
uh because their body parts look
different so
um basically the queen will typically
have a
larger abdomen as a as compared with its
head size
and then also her thorax the middle part
of her body
uh is more they basically look different
i please keep asking questions just
while we do i'm going to
try to set us up to
look at these ants under the microscope
um all right amari yeah this is this is
right here a picture of
ants uh under the microscope and i'm
i'll try to get this set up good go
ahead and ask the question
would happen if the um ant died while
they're laying eggs
the ant died while laying eggs
uh it depends sometimes sometimes the
egg would survive and sometimes it might
not
um i'll try to
see if i can zoom in to where you guys
can actually see these eggs
so these ants are on top of
a combination of eggs
and pupae which are basically
little it's like the cocoon stage of a
of a moth or a butterfly
right here these things right here these
are eggs of these ants
these as well and the black
the the brown ants are walking on top of
the the white
or sort of clear looking eggs right here
all right janika ask your question
if the queen what happens if the queen
ant dies
oh wonderful question um
when the queen ant dies typically she
she's the main
reproducer in the colony she's the main
egg layer
so the colony will usually die
unless a new queen can enter the colony
and become
the new queen but otherwise
they might die or sometimes they'll fuse
with another colony depending on the
species
all right james you have a question
okay my question is like
what would it have been
do you have like a live image or
anything of like a
queen bee i mean not practicing
a clean end
unfortunately we don't have any clean
ants in the lab
so i can't do that right now but i could
at some point send your teacher a video
of that
thank you that would be great
this is fun so here you can see little
baby larvae
um so
we're under the microscope here that's
what this
this sort of looks like an egg but you
can see it's sort of moving around it's
moving its head around
that's like a little baby begging for
food basically
and she is interacting with it
all right amari go ahead and ask your
question
is the um is the queen ant the protector
of regular ants
very good question and the answer is
emphatically no
well most of the time she is basically
um just she's basically just a
reproducer which means that
in a typical ant colony she is the
mother of all of the
the ants in the colony but it's really
her daughters the workers that
protect her most of the time um
usually when the colony is starting up
though she might be involved in
protecting her young
but once the colony has become
established
she is more involved in just laying eggs
and they're involved in feeding the
young
and grabbing the food and protecting her
okay how about alviras
i have two questions one question
is are there any boys
the answer is yes um
they don't play much of a role in the
life of the colony they basically
uh are only involved in
uh mating and then they don't they don't
really play a role in the colony life
so i don't have any right now but
they're you can tell them apart because
they have wings
and then they have tiny little heads
maybe i can send a picture of those too
another question is why did you choose
to study ants
that's a great question well it's it's
because
like i mentioned before all ants live in
colonies
um and that's just always been
fascinating to me they're always
involved in
in behaviors together they
the life cycle of a colony is is so much
more
complex than the life cycle of an
organism a single individual basically
um and ants are a great place to study
how that works
uh and yeah
how it evolved basically
all right how about giovanni
um how did the queen be get
big ah that's a good question
um so
[Music]
hm let me let me think about this for a
second
there are sort of two answers
to that question
one of them is basically that it's it's
what she it's what she
it has to do with uh what the
environment was like when she
was um being raised so basically
she sort of received more nutrition
basically and so she was able to
get bigger because of that then the
other
answer to that is sort of why do large
individuals become queens um
and the answer is basically that in ants
if an if any individual reaches large
body size they will also
have the capacity to lay lots of eggs
whereas if they
are at large at small body size they
they don't they have much
more limited capacity to lay eggs
okay dakari
my question is um where are the queen
ants originally from
originally from i'm not sure
uh what do you mean exactly
where were they born they they're born
in the same colonies that
uh the worker ants are born in um
it's just that some individuals
depending on maybe the time of year
or this is the part of the nest or
the time of day they were laid or
something some individuals get to eat
more than others or
get to eat higher quality food than
others
all right so how about um
uh oh here's um william why don't you
join us for a question
before you said where you get ants or
from the fields
but you said you have many different
species
were they all bunched together or did
you get them separated
um yeah they they all live in um
so yeah typically a single ant colony
that you find
will only have one species and you can
find
lots of different species of ants um
i would imagine if you guys went outside
right now and started looking for ants
you would find several different species
pretty quickly
the different species will often lift
and live in different types of nests but
they can all be
in the same single location that you're
looking in
um does that sort of answer your
question
um yes it does yeah and
well also the the ants that we study
that we like very much they
they are i mentioned that they are
invasive they're native to bangladesh
but they're found everywhere in the
world that is tropical
they're not found anywhere that's more
temperate like the united states
or anything at least not naturally we
have them here but we brought them here
um and we think that's because they
basically can
they like it warm and they can't stand
cold temperatures
justice please go ahead and ask your
question
can ants get sick absolutely they can
and they do um
so i'll just show you
uh it's pretty sad um
but i think there was a
a dead ant one of these problems yeah
there's
dead hands in this one um
so this colony has some several ants
that got sick and died
um
you can see one of them right here i
think
that right there is currently a dead ant
uh so presumably it got sick beforehand
there are a few ways that can happen um
you can have an infection like with a
virus or with bacteria
or commonly in the lab fungus
um it can also starve to death
which we we try to avoid at all costs
because we like to keep these things
alive
um but yeah and and then
you you can you might imagine in in in
the in the common year
that ant colonies are a place where it's
hard to socially distance and
they're in fact they they don't
basically so
if one ant gets sick it's very likely
that other members of the colony
might get sick as well
okay we have a few minutes left but
jaden it would be
super great if you could ask your
question
or i'm not sure maybe jayden doesn't uh
okay i think jaden might have lowered
their hand
so how about there was a question in the
chat too
yeah go ahead oh sorry she asked if i
can memorize every species of ants
um i probably could
if i wanted to but i've never tried
um the nice thing though is that you can
sort of break them down into
groups um so for instance the
the ants that we study are close
relatives of army ants
so i can sort of mentally categorize
them into that group
and then think about them that way so i
have a shorthand way of memorizing
useful groups of dance so jaden
is having technical difficulties but
we'll type their question
in but in the meantime can we hear
from juanas
um so my question is what is the
scientific name of the fire
uh and i think it was called
yeah so fire ants are in the
i'm gonna type it in the chat fire ants
are in the genus
solenopsis and the name of the
species that's invasive in the american
southeast is
solenopsis invicta
and then there are other ants that are
there are other fire ants that are
actually native to southern us
and one of the species that i actually
have studied previously
is called solenopsis geminata
oh and just while i'm naming names the
ants that we study in the lab
are called clonal greater ants
and their scientific name is oh surea
b-roy that's just for fun
that's a very fun name um i think the
class has to leave at 2pm
so that it gives us two minutes and
maybe we can take jaden's question
what inspired you to study ants
that's a great question so i um
i basically was interested in ecology
for a long time
and i was studying abroad in costa rica
which is a very tropical area and
there's a type of ant that lives there
called a leaf cutter ant
i'd encourage you guys to look them up
if you're interested but basically what
they do is they will cut little bits off
of leaves
and they will carry them in lines that
look like highways
from the plant that are carrying it from
back to their nest and
basically i was walking around and i
just realized that i was crossing an
ant highway with all these ants carrying
leaves on their backs and i i leaned
down to look at them
and then i noticed that on the leaves
there were little bitty ants
well on the leaves they were just like
half the size or even the third of the
size of their sisters maybe i can find a
picture of this descend also
but she the little aunt riding the leaf
was cleaning the leaf while it was being
carried
um and i just found this fascinating so
that that's what inspired me to study
ants and i haven't been able to
to kick the habit yet
sounds amazing um ms doherty i think
uh is there a way that we can maybe
make sure that everybody gets an
opportunity to get some questions
answered could we
potentially uh have them written down
and maybe we can get back
with the pictures and a couple of
answers here and there
is that something that would be helpful
yeah great i can compile them and send
them to you if you guys are cool with
that
okay not that i want to make more work
but maybe each person in your lab can
can maybe take a question
and uh and send an answer back if that's
okay because
i love how engaged and how passionate
you all
are about asking questions and that's
really what science is all about is
asking questions so
you're participating as as many
scientists
right now uh by talking about this
research so thank you so
much um kip thank you for your time
uh your work is super fascinating and
i'm so glad that
we were able to showcase that to our
lovely scholars on the other end of our
zoom
and i hope one day you'll get to come to
rockefeller university
and either to visit or to become a
scientist because
that's where scientists study uh it's a
great place to come
um yeah any any other final
thoughts that we should share miss
dougherty or kip
i just wanted to emphasize what what
genie said which was you guys had
wonderful questions today and that you
know many of these questions are right
in line with the kinds of
things that we try to think about and
try to answer uh when we're studying ads
so
keep stay curious uh go look at some
ants if you want
and just you know keep questioning